so this is it i'm in my bathroom the
first night that i'm gonna be doing my
ivf treatment i'm excited i
have two injections to do i'm gonna keep
it
real with you guys well the needle is
definitely longer and thicker
peta murgatroyd is sharing her and
husband maxim schmerkowski's journey to
baby number two it's something she's
been thinking about since 2017 months
after welcoming their first kiddo sun
shy the next one is a girl it would be
easier with another little boy it'll be
like oh my gosh on wednesday peta shared
this video looking fresh-faced in a gray
crop sweatshirt giving herself the first
of many ivf injections gosh these
instructions are really funny
they're like jabbing it into the side
i shan't be jabbing it into the side i
shall be doing it
well the needle is definitely longer and
thicker
finito
i feel fine it's done the dancer keeps
it light talking about the possibility
of weight gain as a result of the
treatments actually luckily my husband
likes the little extra
like pushing for the cushion so you know
what i'm saying
it's fine
success
it's done
it's done
peta's video comes just one day after
revealing she suffered multiple
miscarriages including one while max was
in ukraine where he was helping with
refugee relief efforts amid russia's
invasion people are getting tired
and this is the time that i would like
to ask everybody to
realize that it isn't just it didn't
not end or slowed down e.t was there
when he made his return to the u.s peta
was there to greet him the couple
overwhelmed with emotion max what does
it mean to be home no i just don't want
to present peace somewhere else because
of what i just saw and that's that's the
reality to
understand how that works but
i don't know really what to say
at the time a source told et that peta
was thrilled to have max home with her
and their five-year-old son shy but she
has been going through it and has been
worried sick and emotional and when e.t
caught up with the couple in april they
shared how relieved they were to have
max home again eight days
were
life-changing
absolutely life-changing i mean i
literally wrote him a text
almost a goodbye text like if something
happens oh don't make me cry i'm lucky
with the foundation that we have
the type of relationship that we have
and
you know
i felt really bad because she was
telling me not to go up there so with
every
you know sane person now the two are
focusing on expanding their family and
for peta she's staying positive guys i
know there's no promises
i know that this is
you know a risk a gamble we don't know
what's going to happen but
i think this is the most excited i've
been in
[Music]
a very long time
[Music]
you